yeah i just spit i hope my grandma never
watches this
what's up i'm joelle i'm danielle i'm
micah and i have
never made kimchi before my family is
half chinese half korean and growing up
both cultures definitely had a
heavy impact on our upbringing however i
never took the time to learn how to make
some really fundamental
korean and chinese dishes and kimchi is
undoubtedly
one of the pinnacles of korean cuisines
i decided to challenge my sisters
on this wonderful learning experience
each of us will be making our own kimchi
without a recipe for the first
time and after we let it stew and
ferment my parents are going to do a
blind taste test
and see which of our kimchi's is the
most accurate
to be honest i'm not much of a cook in
general i would say that
i'm a big frozen dumplings kind of
person in general in the kitchen i'm
very comfortable i love to cook for my
family i
am not comfortable in the kitchen well
okay i can make pasta
so i know there is cabbage which i
salted for all of us
gochujang red pepper flakes which is the
go-to garu
there are those baby shrimp thingies
sugar
i think there's garlic fish sauce is
that it
it's calling on the ancestors to come
through
i like how they are like these measuring
spoons as if i have any idea
like how much of anything should go in
there
i don't know this is like a tablespoon
all i know about the kimchi preparation
process is that it's effectively a paste
that you make
and then you just rub all over the
kimchi you let it sit for like a week
i know that it's usually done in like
big batches like
i think normally and in like korean
dramas you see them doing it like
pounds and pounds of cabbage even my
grandma when she would do it i think she
did it like for a huge batch at a time
oh my gosh a serving size is one
tablespoon
so i'm gonna assume that i should use a
whole tablespoon being able to make
traditional korean dishes is really
important to me because i feel like
growing up in
a asian american home second third
generation it's definitely harder to
connect with my
cultural roots is because growing up in
america our parents are taught to
assimilate
so it wasn't necessarily part
of growing up to do some really key
things that i think were probably more
normal
back in my parents day the teaspoon too
much sugar
oh well uh i would say that this is
probably something i feel guilty not
knowing how to do
and that's it so i'm mixing my three
things together
okay yeah i don't know what else goes in
it it's too
thick he's chunky i just spit
they're gone what do i add
i can see antennas from the shrimp which
is making me think that maybe i should
have cut them up
too right now now i'm just going to add
shrimp juice and not add the salt
it tastes too sweet i think it needs
salt i think it needs this
you you shrimp liquids okay i'm putting
in a tablespoon of shrimp sweat
so now i think i'm just gonna shove it
in there
i feel like i hope my grandma never
watches this video
this is my um you know i just got it
this is my cabbage bb
can you like hear it
i feel like i'm like massaging a sea
creature or something
this is my kimchi so this is my final
look
stick her in the fridge and hope that
it's not disgusting in a week
i am chinese american and i am 100
korean ethnically when i got married
into
my husband's korean family my mother was
a very good cook and taught me how to
make a lot of korean dishes like
kimchi
well it's not good but it's not horrible
i'm gonna clean my palette
i thought it was okay out of ten what do
you read it
three i would say five i'm going in for
the second one
i'm afraid to taste the big piece i just
want a little piece
hmm i would almost say this might be the
store-bought one because it's pretty
good
it's very fermenting which i don't like
i like fresh kimchi the best but i like
it i give it a
uh eight i give it a three it definitely
got pieces too big
too much sauce
texture looks like it looks like
that's not edible that is not good
over salted and put way too much i don't
know something
i sort of like it not edible what i sort
of like
i love salty i would have to give that a
zero out of ten
sorry probably a six i'm getting looking
for another small piece
this one's like so fresh there's not
enough salt so it just tastes like
cabbage a little light yeah i like
kimchi actually the flavor's
okay it's very it's like that fish sauce
flavor is gone i would eat it with some
rice so i'd give that a
six three it's just because we have very
different teeth
then number two a store-bought i would
say danielle did the least flavored
micah and joelle that was my initial
impression too
well i actually think that's joelle this
is danielle this is micah should i do it
over yeah micah store-bought i'm two out
of two
i'm three out of three four out of four
oh my gosh
daddy got it thank you very much people
have very different opinions about what
they like in terms of spiciness
you can't really say one is right or
wrong oh no your preference
when you taste really good kimchi you'll
know it's good
normally in making kimchi everyone
starts out salting the cabbage
they let the cabbage soak in the salt
for about minimum of five
hours depending on how much salt you use
you'll rinse off all the cabbage
and you'll make a paste that is composed
of
the red pepper flakes called gochucaro
baby salted shrimp
it's called sewage fish sauce garlic
and ginger good job girls
you